Gladys Knight sings a flawless national  anthem while Adam Levine goes shirtless  for Super Bowl 53 the biggest night in  football kicked off with the 74 year old  singer taking the stage in Atlanta  Georgia for the much-anticipated game  between the Los Angeles Rams and the New  England Patriots  [Music]  maroon 5 frontman Adam Levine had a few  outfit changes during the halftime show  but the one that got everyone talking  was when he decided to wear nothing at  all on top and he was clearly ready for  his close-up  [Music]  the 39 year old singer started off the  set by dedicating the performance to the  band's late manager and Jonah Hill's  brother Jordan Feldstein agility Adam  and the band was later joined by rapper  Travis Scott while his girlfriend and  baby mama Kylie Jenner adorably watched  backstage with their one-year-old  daughter storming former Outkast member  Big Boi also took the stage giving us  all the throwback feels with their 2003  hit the way you move  [Music]